の最後のところ
プネチャパランビッケビックーセイエターピパッセイエサリーランシーヴェティカーヤチャッディタンエーカーハマタンワーディーハマタンワーティーハマタンワーウッ
ドゥマータカングヴィニーラカングヴィプッブカジャータンソーイマメヴァカーヤンウパサンハラティアヤンピコーカーヨーエーワンダッモエーワンバーヴィエータンアナティートー
ティ
イティアジャッタンワーカーエーカーヤーヌパッシーヴィハラティバヒッダーワーカーエーカーヤーヌパッシーヴィハラティアジャッタバヒッダーワーカーエーカーヤ
ーヌパッシーヴィハラティサムデヤダッマヌパッシーワーカーヤスミンヴィハラティヴァヤダッマヌパッシーワーカーヤスミンヴィハラティサムデヤヴァヤダッマヌパッシーワーカーヤスミンヴィハラティ
アッ
ティカーヨーティワーパナッササティパッチュパッティターホーティヤーヴァデーヴァニャーナマッターヤパティッサティマッターヤアニッスイトーチャヴィハラティ
ナチャキッチーローキーウパディヤティエーワンピコービッキャヴェービックーカーエーカーヤーヌパッシーヴィハラティ
テキストの九番目に書いてあるところだと思いますけど
あの この場合はこの体のことを観察する瞑想で
この死体を瞑想することなんですね
プネチャパランビッケヴェービックー
またもう一つの瞑想法がありますと
セイヤターピパッセイエサリーランシーヴェティカーヤチャッディタン
パッセイエっていうのは見つかります
見えますということで見えるでしょうと
サリーラン体をシーヴェティカーヤ
まあ墓場にチャッディタん捨てていること見えるでしょうと
見つかるでしょうと その死体はエーカーハマタン
死んで一日経っているか
ディーハマタン二日経ってるか
ティーハマタン三日間経ってるか
まあそれぐらいの一日
二日 三日 四日ぐらい まあ死んでから経ってる死体
まあ墓場に捨てているのは見つかると
その死体の状態はウッドゥマータカング
ん まあ膨張して まあほんのちょっと膨らんでいるということで
ヴィニーラカング赤くなっている
赤くじゃなくて青く もうこうですか
ヴィプッブカジャータンっていうのは次の言葉っていうのは
まあ醜くなっているってことない
これはあの なんか読めないですね
もう 膿ですかね 膿ただれた死体
で まあ一応二日 三日 四日経ったりすると
まあそういう遺体の状態で
まあかなりまあ膨らんじゃって
それから青黒くなってしまって
まああちらこちらでほんのちょっとあの垂れたりとか
まあ鼻とか目とか まあそういうところからかなりこの膿が出ていたりするんですね
そういう死体を見ると
それで見て まあ自分の体を観察する
イマメヴァカーヤンウパサンハラティ
この遺体を見ながら まあ自分の体を観察するんですね
アヤンピカーヨー この体も
エーワンダッモ このようなものだと
エーワンバーヴィ このような状態になってしまうんだと
エータンアナティートーと
こうならないことはありませんと
必ずしもこのようになりますと
まあ自分の体も映してみるんですね
この状態を 私の体もこのようになるんだと
えーと まあそれから 普通のサティを観察するこの見方がセットありますから
アッジャッタン内なる体を見る
外の いわゆる中から見る
外から見るということで
この場合は簡単で 自分の体もそういうように膨らんで汚く見にくくなっていくんだということを観察して
これ決してそうならないことはありませんと
確実にそういう状態になるんだと見る
それから 他の人々のことにしたっても同じことだと
この世の中にどんな人であろうが
もう必ず死んで こうやって膨らんで
もうゴミを引っ張られるようになってしまって
見にくくなるんだということを見てみる
それで一般的にアッジャッタンバヒッダーワーカーで
どんな体にしても同じことだと観察する
サムデダンマヌパッシーワーカーヤスミンイエレティ体っていうのはどのように生まれてくるものかということも観察してみる
ワヤダンマヌパッシーワーカーヤスミンイエレティ体というのはどのように消えていくかということを観察する
で サムデワヤダンマっていうのは
その両方をまとめてみると
それでアッティーカーヨーティワーパナスサティパッチパッティターホーと
それで彼が確実に確認する
何かアッティーカーヨー
このような体ですよと
世の中にあるのは この今まで観察したような状態の体ですよ
確実に確固たる真理はそういうことだよと
それは変化しないんです
ですから 体っていうのはこのようなものですよという理解が生まれていきますね
で それはヤーデーワニャーナマッターイ
このわずかな知恵につながっていくんですね
パティッサティマッターイ
このある落ち着きにつなげていくんですね
いわゆるサティがつくということなんですけど
どんな体でも 今自分が観察している体と同じ状態になりますと
ただそれだけのことだと
体っていうのはいろいろなものから出てきて
また毎日壊れてかけていって
最終的には死んでしまったらこういう風になってしまう
だからそこら辺で何の騒ぎかという感じで落ち着いてくるんで
だから世の中の身の人のものすごい巨大な騒ぎでしょう
体に対して それは全てもう何のこともないんだと
何の騒ぎかと 自分がほんのちょっと落ち着くんですね
食べ物のことにして 食料のことやら
経済的なことやら おしゃれのことや
いろんなことで みんなっていうのは大変大騒ぎでしょう
何のことかと ということで落ち着きますと
アニッストーチェビヘレティ
この人は だから世の中に対してもうあれやりたい
これやりたい あれ欲しい
これ欲しいとか 困ったり
悩んだり もう混乱したりすることは何のことなくなっちゃうんですね
すごく落ち着くんですね
全て無意味っていうことをわかってね
ネチェケンチローギウパイリ
何者にもとらわることがない
エワンビッケレカーヤカーヤヌパッシベディ
そのようにも 体のこと
体の瞑想でそれぐらいのことは得られますと
で 同じこと だから死体はまあ自分がどんな死体見つかるかわかりませんだから
まあいろんな死体の日にち経つ状況を見ながら
またいくつかの瞑想はだいたい九つぐらいありますけどね
例えばこういう風に体が見つかるかもしれません
十番目
プナチャパランビッケウェービックーセイヤタアピパッセイヤサリイランシーワティカーチャッディタンカーケーヒワカッジャマーナンクラーレーヒワカッジャマーナン
グィッジェーヒワカッジャマーナンスナケーヒワカッジャマーナンシガーレーヒワカッジャマーナンヴィヴィデーヒワパンカジャーテーヒーカッジャマーナンパーナカ
ジャーテーヒーカッジャマーナンソーイマメーヴァーカーヤンウパサンハラティアヤンピコーカーヨーエワンダッモエワンバーウィーエワンアナティートーティーイテ
ィアジャッタンワーエーカーヤーヌパッシーヴィーハラティバイダーワーカーエーカーヤーヌパッシーヴィーハラティアジャッテバイダーワーカーエーカーヤーヌパッシ
ーヴィーハラティサムデダッマーヌパッシーワーカーヤスミンヴィーハラティバイダッマーヌパッシーワーカーヤスミンヴィーハラティサムデバイダッマーヌパッシー
ワーカーヤスミンヴィーハラティアッティカーヨーティワーパナッササティパッチャッティターホーティヤーヴァデーヴァニャナマッターヤパティッサティマッターヤ
アニッシットーチャヴィーハラティーナチャキンチローケーウパディヤティーエワンピコウビッカレービッコーカーエーカーヤーヌパッシーヴィーハラティー
で 二番目の体見つかる死体っていうのは
プナチャパランビッケ
またもう一つありますと
セイヤタアピ 例えばということで
パッセイヤサリイランシーヨティカーチャッディタン
墓場に捨ててるあの死体を見つかります
その死体は カーケーヒワカッジャマーナン
まあカラス カラスですね
まああっちこっちまあ食べてるんだと
クラーレーヒってどんな動物でしたっけ
タカ タカ  タカかな ワシか
その次がハゲタカですから
じゃあまあ え？ その次
十一番がアオサギです
アオサギ で クラーラっていうのはそれタカですかね
まあそういうまあ肉食べる動物ですからね
タカ それから二番目の動物はハゲタカ
食べられたり で こちら十一番目書いてるのは
アオサギって読むのかな
そう アオサギです 猛禽類
猛禽類のアオサギっていう鳥です
カラスの大きいようなやつでしょ
青っぽい 濃色の  どっちにしても肉食の鳥ですよね
猛禽類っていうんですよね
うんうんうん そうそうそうですね
だから鳥の名前とか別にそっちに関係ないんですけどね
で あの まあそうやってまあ鳥たちが来て
まあ食べている それからスナケーヒカッジャマーナン
犬 野良犬とか来てね まあそれ食べている
それからシガーレーヒワカッジャマーナン
まあシガーラっていうのはキツネ
まあジャッカルですけどね
まあそういうキツネが食べているとかね
あるいはヴィヴィデーヒパーナカジャーテ
いろいろ動物たちが来て食べてるんだと
で そういう死体を見つかると
見つかったらあの前と同じ観察をする
だからここで死体があって
いろんな動物たちが来て
一匹取って食べてるだけのことで
で そこであの肩書きもないし
男も女でもないし もう何のこともないんですね
動物たちにとってはもう何のことない
お化けが出てくるか 成仏しているかないかとかね
成仏するまで食べたらあかんとか
そういうこと考えることでも何もなく
もう食べてしまう だからそこで自分の体に瞑想を持っていくんで
その状況を持ってきて
まあこの体の確実にそんなことになるんだと
で こういう状況から逃げている
もう解放しているっていうことは決してありえないんだと
で 死んじゃったらただの肉ですね
ということになるんだと
だからまあそれで 自分の体だけではなくて
どんな人の体にしたってもね
どんな動物の体にしたっても
結局死んだらそんなもんですね
ただの何かの動物の食料になるだけのこと
そういうふうに見てみると
それでまた体の現れる方法と見ると
滅する方法とかね その両方もう観察して
そうやっていろんな現れが
こういう場合はどんな見方でもいいんだ
だから生と死と滅すっていうのは見方いろいろありますけどね
例えばこの体の寒でどのように現れてくるかと
どんな現れ方でもいいんですね
我々世の中を見ていると
毎日毎日新しい新しい体が生まれてくるでしょうに
いろんなところで動物の世界を見ても
いつでも見られるんですね
新しい体が生まれてくる
そうやってまた新しい肉体が生まれ
また新しい肉体が生まれ
またこっちが新しい肉体が生まれてくる
それ一つの我々 それから餌を探して食べて
餌を探して食べてとかね
どんどんそういうふうに大きくなるんだと
それで体が減っていくことも
餌を食べて大きくなると
途中に同時にまた体減って減って減っていくんですね
まあ運動したり 怪我したり
いろんなことをやったりすると体が減っていったりするし
で そういうことでも こうやって体がいろんな体が生まれていく
生まれてきた体はいろんな方法で栄養をとって
餌を食べたりして大きくしちゃうし
それでまたいろんなこと出来事があって
毎日毎日また減ってみて
やがて死んでしまっちゃった
それで単なる食料になって終わってしまうと
それだけの道は確実に
誰にでも普遍的で同じなんですね
ですから この絶対的なんですね
そこだけは真理であって
子供が見たらこの子頭が良さそうだからね
本当にすごい弁護士さんになるではないかって
そういうのはまるっきり真理ではないんですね
それは万人に共通なことではないしね
あるいはこの子はちょっと体が弱そうだからね
将来は心配ですよとかね
そういうのはもうただの人間の妄想の世界だけであって
普遍的な真理じゃないんですね
小さい時は体弱いんだからって言って
大人になっても体弱いわけでもないし
小さい時が元気だからといって大人になってもすごい元気ってわけでもないし
親が長寿だから子供長寿というわけでもないし
親は短命だからといって子供短命
そんなこと何一つもない
人間の好き勝手な考え方で言うだけのことなんですね
もうたとえ遺伝の問題で癌になるんだと
それでは 100%じゃないんです
今偉そうに 100%だよと言ってるんだけど
そうでもないんです そんなものは決して普遍的な真理でもなんでもないんですね
遺伝に何の結果もなくても
癌になる人もいるし だからそういうのには真理と言わないのはこの普遍的ではないんだから
永遠的にその通りということはないんですね
その時その時条件変えればもう変わってしまっちゃう一時的な幻想なんですね
でもこちらで見るのはそういう一時的
的な現象ではありません
誰にでも同じことだと
今人間がもう生きてるよりは死んだら死体にものすごい執着しているんだから
それはもう綺麗に巻いて
なんとかの入れ物に入れて燃やして
もう大事に大事に骨を持っていって
骨の前で泣いたり叫んだりするんですけどね
それは決して智慧の人やっていることではなくて
いかに愚かどもがやることなんですね
だから人間が文明発達したんだからといって
この葬式 儀式 儀礼やったり
それはもうただ頭がどんどん悪くなってるっていうことだけで
頭がしっかりしてるんで
人が死んじゃう 死んじゃいましたら捨てればいいんです
森に 誰か食べなさいよと
その方が一番正しくて役に立ちますからね
論理的だからね それはしないでしょうね
で まあだからそれはまあ例えばイスラム教だったら
人が死んじゃったら もし体の一部がないとものすごく困るんですね
なぜかと天国に行ったらその部分がなくなっちゃうんだと
ですから 人を捌く場合は一番きつく
ものすごく怒って こいつは永久的に捌いてやろうと思ったら
手を切断する 足を切断すると
首を切るということをするんですね
首を切って別々な場所に埋めたりする
じゃあざまあみろと 天国に行ったっても首がないと
だからもうそれぐらい
まあのこと考えてるんですね
それですごい素晴らしい教えだと
心の世界というのはまるっきりわかってないから
単なる怒りと憎しみだけしか私には見えませんだけど
だからといって怒りバラバラらしいんですが
天国にも頭があって足があって
何のために天国にいる連中には頭やら足やら口やら目やらある必要あるんですかね
天国もただいい加減に考えるんだからね
もし天人たちに足があるんだったら
あいつら歩かなくちゃいけないでしょうね
人間っていうのは足があったって車で行ったりするんだからね
何考えてるかさっぱりわからないんですね
天国で歩く どこまでどこからどこまで歩かなくちゃいけないんで歩く
仕事に行ってるんですかね
口があるんだから そうすると食べなくちゃいけないんですね
食べなきゃ体が壊れるっていうこと
我々と同じでしょうにね
そうやって もう人間ってくだらんことを考える
自分の体を結局自分の体を見て欲でイメージ作ってるだけなんです
だからこちらでお釈迦様ははっきりと自分の体を見なさい
死体を見たら自分の体を見なさいと
ということで それしか人間に考えられませんだから
こういう天国を作ってる人々も
もう自分の体を見て 口があってよかったと
いろんな美味しいものを食えるんだと
で そういう天国にはやっぱり口がなければ美味しいものは食えないんだと
そうすると天国にはこんな食べ物じゃなくて
もう極度に美味しい甘露みたいなものは食べ物はあるんだと
考えてないのは なんで食うんですかということなんで
食わなかったら死んだよということでしょうね
食わなかったら体が病気になって弱くなって大変苦しみ味わっちゃうんだから
それだったら天国にいた同じことなんですね
食べなかったら死んじゃいますからね
苦しんで飢え死になっちゃいますから
だから天国に行ったら死なないというならば
食う必要ないんです だから口はいらなくなっちゃうんです
だからもう神様の形で人間を作ったんだと
キリスト教で言ってるし
イスラム教も大体同じ教えだからね
あまりにももう考える必要ではないほどの幼稚的なガキ的なガキの考え方なんですね
ガキどもの だからそれよりは日本で言ってるこのお化けには足がないんだというのは
もうもっとマチな考え方なんですね
足がいらないんだから
ないんだから 足があるとあっちこっち歩いていくんですね
それ困っちゃいますから
じゃあ足がないことにしましょう
スリランカの人々はこのお化けには影がないと
いろんな霊たちが人間の形で来て
目の前に来たっても 喋ったりしたっても
もし影がなかったらもう人間じゃないんだと
だから我々に見せている体はインチキだから
本当の体だったら光が当たって影が映るはずなんですよと
ですからもう幻覚で見せてるんだから
じゃから なんか人が変なこと言うと
ちょっと影見たら影がないんだったら
まあもうこれはもう幽霊やらということでもう気をつけなさいという風に言ってるんですね
だからそういう考え方はもっともっとほんのちょっと理屈はあるんです
だからなんで口があるかという質問も成り立たないんだから
口があっても体があっても
あれは本物じゃないということで
人間を騙すためにそうやって見せかけてるだけだから
でも徹底的に天国を信じている
天国に行ったら永久的にそこで永遠に楽しめるんだという人々は
もうそういう風には思ってないんですね
まあとにかくまあ
まあ体っていうのは誰の体でも死んじゃったらそうやっていろんなカラスやらハゲタカやらワシやらいろんな鳥たちが食べたりするんじゃするんだと
まあそれは普通自然自然的なことなんですね
それは違いますよと 人間食べたら人間死んじゃったら
まあちゃんと富士山見えるところでお墓で永遠に眠ってもらいますというのは
これもあんまりにもバカバカらしい考え方でね
お位牌のとこって座っていろんなことを喋るわ
どこまでもう無知の世界かというと
まあまあキリがないんですけどね
一緒にはあなたと一緒にはお墓に入りたくないとか言ったりする
すごい怒りでしょ もう死んじゃったらもう何もただのもうもう犬に食べさせればいいのに
でまあ 死んでからももうずっといるんだっていう
そう それなのに輪廻のことなんか言うと
まあ腹が立って攻撃すること
本当は相手にしたくないんですよ
あんまりにも頭おかしいんだから
でもお墓は作ってほしいんですね
ブッダが教える輪廻 あんなものは信じません
我々現代人は科学的に物事を考えるんだからと
だけど そうやっても話にならないほど頭がおかしいんですよ
自分が何考えてるかと自分でもわかってないんだから
だから人は何考えててもいいんです
だから子供はもうちゃんと
何でしたっけ？サンタクロースがいるんだと
子供はちゃんとそういるんだと思ってるんだから
別にそれはあまり問題にならないんですね
だから自分が何考えてるかと知ってるんだからね
だからあの子供とちょっと喧嘩になったんだけど
確実にサンタクロースがいるんだと
僕はとんでもない嘘やと
すごくこのクリスマス喜んでる年ですから
わざと嘘だと 見たことがあるんだと聞いたら
親がいないところでね
親は子供を騙したくて騙したいんだからね
親がそこら辺ないんだから
見たことない 嘘です いない
いるわけじゃないんだと
あんたどうやってると言ってるんですかと聞かせたら
だってちゃんとクリスマスにプレゼント来るんだ
これ他の誰かがあんたにあげてるのではないかと
いやいや これサンタクロースあげてるんだ
どうやってサンタクロースだと言うんですか？と言ったら
自分が欲しいプレゼントをちゃんと書いておいたところで
ちゃんとそのものをもらってるんだからね
あ そう なるほど だったらそれは誰にでもできるでしょうに
あんた書いてどこに隠しておいたんですか？そこバレるところに置くでしょうに
と 誰にでもできますよと
だったら夜ずーっと起きていなきゃ
九時半になっちゃうと寝て
また朝八時 七時半まで寝ているんだと
嘘だと でも私はそこまで言ったってことはいいよ
何言ったってもいるんだということもことで
もうしっかりしているんですけどね
何言ったってもいるんだと
私はいえ いませんと だから結局そうやって平行線で話は終わりましたけど
でもそれそう言ったって
私にとってはその子供の考え方は可愛いんですよ
なぜならば それなりにいろいろ証拠があって
もういるんだということははっきり決まってるんだからね
でも大人になってくると
自分が何考えてるかと思う自分でも全然知らないんだからね
輪廻に反対するは 業に反対するは
全てに反対して お墓作ってほしいと
ということなんです まあですから
まあそういうこういうところで
これはまあ全然残酷な考え方ではなくて
普遍的にどんな時でもどんな時代でも確実に起こる出来事なんですね
これは決して避けられないことなんですね
もし体の肉というものは栄養であるならば
それはずっと栄養にはなるんです
だから誰が死んでも もし放っておけば
他の動物に見つかったら
それは食べて食べてしまうんですね
なんかどこかで映画にも作ってあったんですね
なんか飛行機が落ちちゃって
そこでもう冬の中で残った人々は
まあもうその友達を食べて
やっとまあ生き残りましたというね
映画にもなって なんとかでそれを事実を見たいんですけどね
だから あり得ない映画作ることまでじゃな
ごく普通なことでしょうね
いまだに我々は死体食べて生きてるんだから
人間肉食べたんだからって
そんな珍しいことでも変なことでもなんでもないんです
今も同じく肉食べて体大きくしているでしょうし
人間でおかしいことってのは
鶏肉食べるとあれ死体食べてると思わない
魚食べ死体食べてるとは思わない
豚を食べ死体食べると思わない
そこで人が猫を食べるとなんだこの人変な人ですねと
猫を殺して食べてるんだと
あれ何なのかとわからないんですね
猫食べたってヘビ食べたってゴキブリをあのアサリの代わりにね
味噌汁にゴキブリ入れて食べたって全然何のこともないんです
まあ結局まあただ決めつけちゃって
これこれ食べるんだと
これこれ食べない 他の人々は食べるでしょうね
中国文化ではね 食べないもの何もないんだから
人間以外は でももうそれもわからないんですよ
もう中国人だからいつでも豊かだったわけでもないし
巨大な国ですからね あるところは豊かにあるところはもう乾季でもう飢えているということがいくらでもありますからね
食べたことはあると思いますけど
そういうふうなことを見て観察していくと
いやいや ただの普通の死んでる犬と
まあまあ普通のまあ牛とかね
そういうこと同じくみんな来て
まああの まあテレビ見たらね
いくらでもこのアフリカのいろんな番組見るとね
まあ動物を死んじゃったところで
他の動物たちがさっとそっちに群がって
もう食べて食べて食べて食べて
終わっちゃうでしょうしね
そしたらまあそういうものやってみると
そうするともう結局サティパティッサティとサティが入ってしまうし
まあ世の中に対するこの大騒ぎが心の中から綺麗に消えてしまうんですね
そこまで大騒ぎする必要あるんだと
あるかということで消えてしまっちゃうんです
はい 次 11番 プナチャパラムビッカヴェビクセイヤタピパッセイヤサリーランシーヴァティカエチャッディタングアッティカンカリカング
サマセマンサローリタングナハルーサンバッダンソーイマメーヴァーカヤンウパサンハラティアヤンピコーカヨーエワンダンモエワンバービーエワンアナティートーティー
次にまた違う形の死体を見つけるかもしれませんね
で その場合はまあほぼあの
何て言いますか 骨組み
見えますけど あっちこっちまた肉もついていて
血もあって もう血管ももういわゆる骨も見えるし
いろんなところでまだ肉やら血やら残っているぐらいの体ですね
いわゆる動物がいくらか食べて逃げていったとかね
もう綺麗に全部食べるということはないし
だからある動物によって骨も折って食べる場合もあるしね
で まあキツネやらはそこまでは食べないでしょうし
肉だけ取っていっちゃうし
で 鳥だったら肉だけ全部取って取って食べて骨は残しちゃうし
で ハイエナやら熊やら来たらまあまあ骨までもう噛んで食べたりするしね
まあそういう風に まあ一応食べ残しのような体を見つかったら
またそんな感じになるんだ
自分の体を観察する で
十二のところの体はアッティサンカリタンニンマンサンローヒタマッキタンナハールサンバンダン
そこでまあもっと時間経った体かもしれません
これはもうアッティサンカリタン
まあ骨だけなんですけど
全部肉食べちゃっ食べられちゃったんですね
動物たちに食べられたんだけど
もうこの筋はまだまだつなげているんですね
骨まで取って取って食べてるわけじゃないんです
例えば体が完全に鳥たちだけに食べられちゃうと
まあ骨とか全部そのままつなげたまんまなんですね
そこでこの肉を取っちゃうと
この太い血管と筋とかはね
もうなかなか切れないんだからね
それはまた残っているんですね
ですから骨組みなんですけど
あまり綺麗というわけじゃないんですね
ものすごく汚れているんですね
そういうものを見たら
あ こんな感じになるんだと
で 瞑想するんです 次の死体は十三
オヌ
チャパランビッカウェービックーセイヤタピパッセヤサリイランシーヴェティカアチャッディタンアッティサンカリタンアパガタマンサローヒタンナハールサンバンダン
で まあほとんど骨だけつなげている
あの骨だけというのは
いわゆるまあ骸骨だけで
でもまだ形ちゃんと整えていますね
いわゆるあのつなげている
まあ雨降ったりするとね
骨がもう綺麗に残っている血とかね
なくなっちゃいますからね
まあそんな風な骨だけの体を見るんだと
次のまたこういう風に死体も見つかるかもしれませんね
十四番目になると オヌチャパランビッカウェービックー
セイエターピパッセイアサリランシーレティカアチャッディタンアッティカーニアパガタサンバンダーニ
ディサヴィディサスヴィキッタニ
アン
ジェーナハッタハッタカッティカンアンジェーパダッティカンアンジェーナゴーパッティカンアンジェーナジャンガッティカンアンジェーナウラッティカンアンジェーナ
ピッティカッティカンアンジェーナカタッティカンアンジェーナカンダッティカンアンジェーナギーワッティカンアンジェーナダンタッティカンアンジェーナシーサッティカン
ソイマメヴァカーヤンパサンハラティ
それでまた違う形の遺体を見つかる
この遺体はもう肉も全部食べられちゃって
まあ血液も全部もう犬たちがね
もう舐めてなくなっちゃって
これで大きな動物が来たら
あっちこっち引っ張ったり喧嘩したりして食べてるでしょうね
そうするともう足を引っ張った人はそこから外して外してますから
ここのところに持っていて
それは食べてそのまま行く
元にこの骨を足の骨戻しておこうってことはないんだから
また まあ他の小さな動物が来たら
もしかするとバラ骨とか引っ張って引っ張って人を襲って持っていってそれ食べるかもしれませんし
で そうやってこのもう全部食べられちゃって
骨もバラバラなんですね
もう人とは言えないんですね
まあ頭はあるところにあるんだけど
もう太ももの骨はまたこっちで
また他のもののところ
他のところで もうもうもう
そうやってもういろんなところにバラバラに散らかしているという
それ見たら こんなもんだと
自分も確実にそうなるんだっていう風な瞑想続けちゃうんですね 15
にあるのはプニチャパランビッケヴェービックーセイエターピパッセイアサリランシーレティカアチャッディタンアッティカーニセータニサンカワンヌパニバーニソーイマメヴァカーヤンパサンハラティ
そこで あの生の死体見つからないかもしれませんだけど
大体見つかりやすいもの見つかるんです
骨だけ見つかる それもかなり
骨っていうのは結構持ちますよ
あのカルシウムだから
ですから まあそんな簡単に水に溶けるということはないし
まあ土に植えてもすぐ簡単に壊れるってことはないんですね
ですから なかなか持ちます
で そういう骨っていうのは
まあ大体カルシウムだから白くなっちゃうんですね
だから白くなっている骨だけ見つかるんだと
です 見たら あ 結局人間っていうのはこれでこんなもんになって終わっちゃうんだと
私もこういう風になって終わるんだと
だから骨一本見てもね
これはまあ元人間の骨でしたけど
今はただの骨だけだ あの世界は意味もなくない
ないんだと今は 自分についたって
自分もそういう風になるもんだと
どんな人でもそういう風になるんだと
いろんなことをして威張っていたっていうのは
結局そんなもんだということで
この世に対する心のこの騒ぎがそれで消えてしまっちゃうんですね
で 次に出てくる死体はまあそれで終わると思いますけど
16番 プニチャパランビッケヴェービックーセイエターピパッセイアサリランシーレティカアチャッディタンアッティカーニプンジカタニテーロワッシカーニ
まあ遺体捨て場に墓場に行ったら
まあ大体ようなところで足が足ではなくて骨がもうあるんだだからまあ誰かが来て全部もうまとめて
まあちょっとまとめて置いておいたと
そこで同じ人の骨ではないかもしれません
そこら辺にある骨 まあ一応まとめてじゃあこちらに入れておこうと
そうやって一箇所にまとめている
もう壊れてかけている
白くなっている 灰色である
また血管もむき出ているとかね
そうやってこのもう古くなった骨ですね
結局はね まとめている骨見たら
まあその時も私もそんな感じになるんだと
私は背が高いとかね 体の色がこの色だとかね
そういう感じも全部なくなって
ただ骨だけになってしまうんだっていうことを感察する
17番目にはプニチャパランビッケヴェービックーセイエターピパッセイアサリランシーレティカアチャッディタンアッティカーニプーティーニチュンナカジャータ
ニソーイマメヴァカーヤンパサンハラティアヤンピカーカーヨーエワンダンモーエワンバーヴィーエワンアナティートーティ
最後に骨は見つからないんだけど
骨も年取っちゃって もう粉々になって
もう石灰状態になってしまって
もう触っただけで もう壊れる
割れてしまうと手で握っても粉にすることはできるぐらいの
まあ粉になっている状態の骨を見ると
それを見たら まあ自分もそういう風な感じになるんだっていう観察するんですね
そこで死体は九つなんですね
死体の瞑想は で 九つも全部やらなくちゃいけないってことではなくて
まあそうやっていろんな形の死体を目にするんだということで
だから結局は死体の瞑想一つだと見ても同じことなんですけど
瞑想のやり方は同じなんですね
ですから たった一本の骨を見ても
この瞑想はできるんですね
この前も話したと思いますけど
この で いろんな経典 何を勉強したっていうも
まあほとんどこの考え方はピチッとまとめているんですからね
お釈迦様はもうある思考方向でこの全部説法を続けているし
それはまあ一応九十道という四つのまあ締まりで言ってるし
あるいは因果法則って
まあ言えばそれぐらいのことだからね
それでかなりお釈迦様馬鹿にしようと思ってる人々いるんだけどね
仏教ってのはこれ死生体と因果法則
因縁と まあ偉そうにこれ何なのかと聞いたりもしますけどね
でも まあとにかく まあ一応考え方はそういう風にしっかりしていて
その中からいろんな説法をしているんですね
そこでこのよく見えることは
この現代の人々に分かりやすく言えば
このこの価値の世界と非価値の世界というのを 2つに分けられますね
で 世の中のすべての学問
知識はこの価値の世界なんですね
価値を探す で探す あるいは作る
価値のないものにわざと価値を作る
ただ水なんかは無料でしょうに
今は水にも価値ついてるでしょうに
それで終わるんじゃないんです
それで水に名前を入れるんですね
名前あるはずがないんだけどね
それでまた価値の差が生まれてくるでしょ
あなたはどんなブランドの水を飲んで水を飲んでるんですかと
だから だからみんなそれほど頭がもうほとんど頭が悪いんだからですけど
いじ-意地悪しようと思っちゃえば簡単にできますよ
春水とかいろいろブランド人気あるでしょうに
そんな感じで 水にもこのブランド飲むのはすごいかっこいいんだと
もう究極的な人気ある人の名前とかなんとか出して
あの人この水しか飲みませんよと言っちゃえば
他のバカどもみんなそれ買うでしょうね
それで見えを張ってその水を見えるように持っていくとかやるでしょ
はっきりとやらせちゃうと
そうすると他のもの水は飲みません
まあそうやってまあもう価値を作る世界
価値を作る世界で 別に意味があるかというと
別に意味があるわけじゃないんです
ただ人は苦しめるためにいろんな価値を作る
もう例えば金といったっても
ただの金属なのに 人間がそれに価値を作ってるんですね
それで大変なことになってるでしょうね
宝石ってのはただの石でしょうに
石ってのはいろんな種類があるんだけど
その中の一種宝石っていうものなんですね
エメラルドにしたっても
別にもう ただの石 まあそこら辺も掘っちゃえば見つかる可能性もあるしね
あ それはそんな簡単ではなくて
すっごい価値入れちゃうでしょうね
で それで大変な世界が生まれてくる
だからこの毎日毎日毎日
このいかにどのように価値を入れるかということだけで人間の思考機関頑張ってるんですね
だから価値を入れる世界っていうのは
ものすごい苦しみの世界で切りがない世界
なぜかというと 価値はいい加減だから
実際にその意味があるわけじゃないんです
例えば ダイヤっていうのはすごい高価なものだったら
万人にダイヤが高価なものにならなきゃいけないでしょうに
それ万人にそれは高価なものっていうわけじゃないんですね
ある一定の愚かどもだけにこれは意味があって
子供には全然 子供には 20カラットのダイヤあげて
じゃあこれをおもちゃにして遊んでくださいと
この子供は世界一幸福感じるんですかね？私はもう 20カラットのダイヤのおもちゃで遊んでいたんだよと
全然そうじゃないでしょうね
そこら辺に売ってる 500円のおもちゃがあげればもっとすごい喜ぶでしょうに
だから価値っていうのはそういうことで
でもあまり 論理的なものではないんですね
で 価値を入れれば入れるほど問題が
あの なんとか 12 キョクですかたっけ
あの鑑定なんとかという番組ありますね
あれ だけの家も国にあるガラクタを集めて 1,000万とかね
500万円とかね で 鑑定するでしょ
で それは全てガラクタで何の役にも立たない
でも人間が感情的に価値入れている
それで 500万円か 1万円かという風にまあ決めちゃうんですね
時々あるガラクタは使っているんだからということで値段下がったりする
これは使った方がもっと値段が上がりますよという場合もあるし
そこで昔の時計だったらね
時間も全く正確ではないし
それでも動いてるんだったら
これ 100万  200万
400万円になるんだとかね
言ったりする もう時計もあるし
でも結局ガラクタ ガラクタなんです
全然 まあ一応動くんだからといって役に立ちますかと
役に立ちません 単なる価値入れてあって
この服のブランドの名前もそうやって
まあ人の愚かさを操って
自分たちの名前だけ売る
それでカバンの使用価値ではなくて
カバンについてるバッジに20万円を払わなくちゃいけないんですね
カバンにはまあまあ 5,000円とバッジに 20万と
それで 20まあ 5万円でとか
まあプロフィットも入りますから
ということで 一応負けてくれないかと
じゃあまあ 3,000円負けてあげます
まあそういうふうな世界で人間っていうのは生きてるんですね
すっごい強力ね 価値作る世界で
だからどこまで価値を作るかということなんですね
どこまででも妄想の世界だからね
価値を作ることはできるんですね
この 昔作った車ありますね
初期段階で そういうもうほとんどこちょこちょこちょこちょであんまりスピードも全然出ませんし
だいたいせいぜい三十キロですね
三十 三十五っていうのはもうやっと出るスピードなんですけど
でも買おうとすれば二
三千万円以上 というふうに
そんなに価値あるかと
鉄だけ見ても どう見ても何もないのに
ただもうクラシック車で昔作った車で今でも動くんだよというぐらいのことで価値入れてるだけ
でも道路ではもう走れませんよ
いろいろ道路基準とかいろんなものありますからね
そんなものあるちゃったら大変迷惑で
そういう価値の世界で
我々にはいろんな並ならぬ苦しみが生まれてくる
例えば 自分の家で古い紙に書いた何か書記でも何でもあったとする
それを鑑定団体が鑑定
今はごく普通にそこらへんあったんだけどね
鑑定したところで これはまあ 一千五百万円の価値があるんだと
で 鑑定してもらったら
その日から自分がどうなるんですかね
そこら辺 家の子供遊んでいたかもしれません
子供たち それに足で蹴っ飛ばしたりしたかもしれない
逆立ちすると子供の足もそちらに付けたりした可能性もあったりしたかもしれませんし
それでなんか変な古くて
これ何なのかとね と思って鑑定すると
これは千五百万円かかる値段がありますよと言われたらまあ大変ですよ
夜も眠れなくなっちゃうし
これ銀行に 銀行に預かっておくか
あるいは自分の家に警備会社のセキュリティシステムをつけておくかどうかね
そういう問題になってくるでしょうね
で 例えばすごい古い家なんかはね
もう住みにくくて みんなもう大変で
これ一旦壊してやるぞと思ったところで
そこら辺の地方の人々が来て
これはまあ大変古くて文化財ですよと認定したら
それで終わり 生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
自分にとっては何の所有もないのに
あれを守らなくちゃいけない
苦労してもう廃墟になっても
その家を改良できないということになるでしょうね
そういうことで この物に
自分にいろんな価値を入れて価値を入れて価値を入れていくんだからこそ
我々はもう大変 いろんな苦しみと出会わなくちゃならないんですね
でお釈迦様はもう簡単にこの価値を解除するんですね
で なんで体をあの色受想行識という五つだけに分けたというと
どんな人の体にしたっても色受想行識しかないんですね
言った途端 あのもう人の価値っていうのはもうもう価値言えませんと
ものすごい価値があるんだよというインチキな話あるでしょうに
人間は評価できませんと
命は尊いんだと 何の力でああいう風に言うんですかね
尊いんだけど 平気で人を殺しているでしょうに
ちゃんと人を測って値段つけてるでしょうに
残酷に で 人事故を起こして人に怪我したらまあこれぐらい値段ですよと
十歳の子供を殺しちゃったらこれぐらいの弁償ですよと
四十歳の人を殺しちゃったらこれぐらい弁償ですよ
あるんじゃないんですかね
だからそれほど価値がないといえばないんですけどね
で 価値入れてそこでもうどんな体にしたっても色受想行識それだけと思ったら
その色には別に価値が色肉体だからね
そんな価値がない まあ牛の肉だったらもう結構値段つきますけど
人間の肉だったらゼロって
価値がないしね じゃあ自分の感情に価値がある
これ全然もうみるみるうちに変化していくものだからね
価値があるところが醜くてもうどうにもならないということでね
そうやってこの五つに分けてみたら
そこで全ての価値が消えるはずなんですね
なぜ全ては無常だということを見なさいと
無常という一言葉で無価値ですよということでも言ってるんですね
だからピカピカ光るんだから金は価値ありませんと言ったっても
それは嘘でしょう ピカピカ光るんだからこそ
金が価値あるわけじゃないんです
他の金よりも光るものあるでしょうね
でもすぐそこはもう長持ちしないんですね
普通のアルミ箔でも もうちゃんと光当たってもらえばね
鏡みたいにね もう金よりはね
もっと鏡とかよく光るでしょうね
でも鏡にはあまり価値入れませんね
なぜならば 金と比べると鏡の方は無常でしょう
短命でしょ だから短命だったら価値は入れません
我々はそこら辺でテント張ったならば
それは一日二日しか持ちませんだからね
それほど価値は入れません
誰かにそれ壊されたってても
まあそんなに大騒ぎはしません
そこで鉄筋で鉄筋コンクリートで家を作ったりする
それはまあ一応二十五年
三十年 四十年は持つよ
それ作って作ったところで
二 三ヶ月間経たないうちにトラックが入り込んじゃってきて
壊れたりすると そこをすごく大騒ぎするんですね
ひびが入っちゃったら
鉄筋のあっちこっちにもう使えないんだから
で なぜかというと そちらにも長持ちするんだから価値があるんですね
なんで人間が命は尊くて価値は言えませんというね
この魂は永遠だと勘違いしてるんだからなんですね
魂さえも見つかってないのに
永遠というもう特色だけは決まってるんですね
あるかのかどうか分からないものなんですけど
それは永遠ですよと言ってることなんですね
ですから この長持ちするという錯覚は価値を作る
それで苦しみが作ると
それで長持ちするというのは錯覚なんですね
本当は長持ちしてほしいという希望なんです
だからそこにお釈迦様は渇愛と言ってるんですね
なんでそんなに永遠論が出てくるかというと
長持ちしてほしいという希望があるんで
心に どんなものについても
炊いたご飯にしたっても
もう三時間で腐るのは嫌でしょう
とにかくちょっと長持ちするように何とか苦労しますね
冷蔵庫に入れたり いえ
冷凍庫に入れておこうとかね
あるいはちょっと酢であの酢を入れておいたら
もうあのあまり早く腐れませんよとかね
あるいは塩で握った方が持ちますよとかね
うん だから人間がそうやって長持ちさせるためには努力をする
でもそこにある真理は長持ちしないということなんですね
長持ちしないということは真理であって
心にはこれは嫌だと この真理は
長持ちしてほしいという価値観があると
だから長持ちするということは錯覚なんですね
自分の心に生まれた夢だけなんですね
幻覚だけなんですね そこでずっとみんな幻覚を追っているんですね
だから 物には価値を入れる
いろんなもう言い訳を作って価値を入れる
そこでどこまでかじられて問題はそのまんまなんですね
ものは長持ちしない 心には長持ちしたい
してほしいという希望がある
で なぜ長持ちしてほしいという希望が生まれたかというと
自分も他もすべてすぐすぐ消えていくんだということを毎日毎日
瞬間瞬間経験しているんですね
だから瞬間瞬間経験しているものは否定する
だから愚かやとしか言う方法ないんです
だから瞬間瞬間経験しているのに
無常ということを否定するんだから
いえ 違いますよと だったら
まあそう言うならば お釈迦様から言えば
お釈迦様の単語では愚か者
愚者という言葉しか出てこないんです
だから すべての生命の人々には愚か者ということを使っているんですね
例えば 我々は毎日ご飯を食べている人
人がね 歳までご飯ばっかり食べてきたんだと
あんたご飯食べてるで
いいえ 全然ご飯食べたことないんだと言ったら
もう大嘘つきで もし真面目に言ったならば愚か者でしょ
ボケてるでしょ ただ嘘つき
いいえ 全然食べたことないんですったら
あんた嘘つきやと言ってものを言いますけど
もしその歳の人がものすごい真面目で
ご飯って何ですかね 食べたことはないんですよと言ったら
もうもう終わりだと この人はもう大ボケやと
ということになるんですね
だから愚か者でしょうね
だったら無常っていうのはもう毎瞬間
毎瞬間感じていて 否定するということは
もうボケた老人と違って
もうもう取り柄つもない愚か者なんですね
そういうことで 生命には
お釈迦様は正しく愚か者という言葉を使っているんです
それでこのすべて無常だから
またそれを否定するんだから
その否定したがる気持ちがこの渇愛といってね
だから渇愛さえ消しなさいよと
それで全て解決するんだと
簡単単純ではないかと
という教えになってしまっちゃうんですね
それでも価値を消せと
価値を消すためには無常
ということをわかればいいんです
まあ瞬間ですよ そういうことで
もう幻想までも物事を分析しなくちゃいけない羽目にもなりました
例えば何でも水の上に書いた線ののように消えてしまいますよと
水の上で書いた絵の文字のごとく
もう書くと同時に消えていきますからね
そのようにすべては瞬間瞬間無常ですと言ったっても
愚かどもがたちがもうやっぱり地球はずっとあるんじゃないかとかね
人が死んだっても この財産はもうもう 20代まで
あるいは 40代まで 5000 年間もからのこの宝物がずっとあるんじゃないかとかね
そうやって何か価値 それでも入れちゃうんですね
これ保存しなくちゃいけないとかね
後の時代の人々にも ためにも保存しておかなくちゃいけないとかね
だから人は死んじゃったんだけど
もう 1000年古いものでも
3000年  3年古いものでも
いくらでもあっちこっちあるでしょうに
で そういうことになってきたら
やっぱりそうすると見てください
そうやってこの時代 時代ものになってくると長持ちしているでしょ
故に価値があるでしょうに
だから見ても面白くてもどうでもない字でもかもしれませんよ
それはもう もう 1000年前で誰かさんが書いたということはしっかりしちゃうと
これはもう博物館にとらわれちゃいますね
個人財産 所有ではよくないんだと
そんなものになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから長く持てるということは
この大変な価値ということ
錯覚が出てきて とにかくこの心は無常を否定することで
それだったら科学的に見てみなさいと
どんなものでも瞬間瞬間変化して変化して
新しいものに変えて変えていくんですね
ですから 古いものは今あるわけはありません
1000年古いものは今見ることは全然不可能なんです
今見ているのは今あるものなんです
これ 1000 年間変化して今になっているだけだから
だから 1億年古い恐竜の化石が見つかったとかね
当時でいた恐竜は今はこれただの化石な石なんですね
だから今見ているのは今のことしか見てないしね
だから物事は瞬間瞬間でいたっても変化していくんだという無常論はものすごい徹底的に喋っているのも
この価値をもうナリファイというかね
価値をこの消すためなんですね
価値を消したところで守ることはなくなっちゃうんですね
守らなくちゃとか ものすごい心の中にあるこの何とかしなくちゃ
何とかしなくちゃという
これはもう消えてしまっちゃって
放っておいて落ち着きます
ですから この生きるの九つの瞑想にしたっても
普通の人間は全然見ようとしない角度で見る
普通の人間 人間見る角度で見たら一向に悟らないんです
一向に智慧が生まれてこない
あれはもう無知の人々の世界だからね
ですから悟るためには
お釈迦様が言った通りのお釈迦様の見方で物事を見なくちゃいけない
たくさん瞑想法あるのはそうやってこの心の訓練なんですね
見方を変えるための訓練なんですね
見方変えちゃったら それで瞑想は成功したというんですね
そちらの例外とすわりまして
何回も出ましたストーリーなんですけど
ある女の子がお嫁に行って
旦那と喧嘩して実家に帰るぞと森の中で帰っちゃうんですね
とにかく男も嫌でもう二度と戻りません
そこであるお坊さんがこの骨の瞑想
この九つの中から骨だけ取って
それはもうみんな骨だけですよとね
自分の体も骨だけであって
もう何もないんや ないんやと
価値も何もないんだと瞑想していて
途中で森の中でこのお坊さん
この女の人出会うんですね
だったら この女の子の立場から見たら
もう自分の旦那よりはかっこいい男の人なんですね
こういう人かっこいいなと思ってもうニコッと笑ったんですね
笑ってもお坊さんもそんな世界のこと考えてるんじゃなくて
この真理の世界の中に頭が回転しているんだからね
みんな骨だと思って瞑想しながら托鉢に出かけようと思うから
もうマジでいいこと思ったことで骨が見えちゃったんですね
歯も骨だからね やっぱり骨だ
それだけで終わっちゃったんですね
やっぱりまあこういう風に
だと思ったところで全部骨に見えてしまっちゃったんです
頭で まあ頭蓋骨だ まあ骸骨だけ
見えたって別に怖いとも何ともなく
それは動いてるんですね
だからあのお坊さんにとっては
女の子が若い人が何々さんが歩いてるっていうことはないし
私とよく仲良く笑ってくれたという
親しく笑ってくれたとかって
全然わからない そんな幻想の世界
実態ってのは骨が動いていると
で 何のことなく通してると
旦那がもう追っかけてくるんですね
この人 そしたらお坊さんにまた会うんでしょうし
こちらこの方向でお坊さんがこちら方向に行くんだから
もう村から他のですね
お坊さんは村に出て帰っているんだから
で 男の人が あ もしかすると同じ道だからこのお坊さん見つかったでしょうって言って
お坊さんに お坊さんを尋ねますけど
ここら辺は若い女の人がいたんですけど
え？女の人？とは見てないんだけど
一応骨 骸骨だけはまあこうやって動いてるのを見ましたよと
お坊さんは正直に本気で言ったんですね
女か男はわからないんだと
骸骨だからそれはないんだと
骸骨は動いてるのを見ましたよと
だからまあこのお坊さんアホではないかと思って帰ったかもしれませんだけど
アホなお坊さんではなくて
その他の人々なんですね
だからそのお坊さんにはこの骨の瞑想はしっかり身についているんですね
だから成功していった人なんですね
ですから このいろんな瞑想あるのは
そうやってこの普通の人間がそう思わないという立場で
で瞑想できてるんです
だからそれにいろいろケチつけたりするのは何の意味もないんです
あなた方はそう思わないんだから
こう思ってくださいと言ってるんだと
で まあ一応体の瞑想はそれで終わります
そこから番目のこの受の瞑想
受の瞑想っていうのは
まあそれはまあ説明としてはそんなに長くはないんです
カタンチャ
ビッキャウェ ビッコー ヴェーダナー スー ヴェーダナーヌ パッシー ヴィハーティ イダ ビッキャウェ ビッコ
ー スカン ヴェーダナン ヴェーディーマノー スカン ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア ミーティ パジャナーティ ドゥッカング
ヴァー ヴェーダナン ヴェーディーマノー ドゥッカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア ミーティ パジャナーテ
ィ アドゥッカ マス カング ヴァー ヴェーダナン ヴェーディーマノー アドゥッカ マス カング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア ミーティ パジャナーティ
一応これワンセット まずこのセットで瞑想しなくちゃいけない
っていうのは体の感覚
で 体の感覚は分かりやすく一応つに分けてみましょうと
そうするとスカン ヴェーダナン
楽感覚 楽しい気持ちですね
体に生まれるんですね
そこは生まれたら 今は楽しい感覚ですと確認する
で ドゥッカは苦しみ痛みの感覚
生まれたら今苦しみの感覚ですと確認する
それからアデュッカマスカ
楽も苦しみとも言えない感覚が生まれている時は
今はそういう感覚が生まれているんだと
不苦不楽の感覚ですと
感覚の世界をきちんと分けて分けて分けて分けた 3つに分けて分けていくんですね
どこまででも分けて分けて分けて
それで心が変わるはずなんですね
だからいい方法っていうのは
どのように変わるかと私に聞いて
それをまた帰って私に報告することなんです
そうするとすごい騙すことはできるんです
で そういう風に騙そうと思ったっていうのは何の意味もないんだけど
必ずしも心は変わるはずなんですね
すべての銃をもう楽と苦と不苦不楽に分けてみる
それしか感覚はないはずなんですね
だから価値を入れるかないかっていうこと
例えば 楽の感覚にものすごい価値を入れてるでしょうね
じゃあどれぐらいやるかと
そうやって見てみればいい
あまり喋っちゃうとね
決まってる人がいるんで
とにかく騙してやるぞと
だから喧嘩になるんだから
そこら辺話をやめます
で それその 3セット終わったら
次にまたもっと感覚を分けて考えることはできますね
サアミサンワーア スカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア マノー サアミサン スカング ヴェーダナン ヴェ
ーディア メーティ パジャナーティ ニラーミサン ワーア スカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア マノー ニラーミサン
スカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア メーティ パジャナーティ サアミサン ワーア ドゥッカング ヴェーダナン
ヴェーディア マノー サアミサン ドゥッカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア メーティ パジャナーティ ニラーミサン
ワーア ドゥッカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア マノ
ー
ニラーミサン ドゥッカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア メーティ パジャナーティ サアミサン ワーア ドゥッカマス
カング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア マノー サアミサン ドゥッカマスカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア メーテ
ィ パジャナーティ ニラーミサン ワーア ドゥッカマスカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア マノー ニラーミサン
ドゥッカマスカング ヴェーダナン ヴェーディア メーティ パジャナーティ
あのヴェーダナーのセットは全部終わりまして
このサアミサ ニラーミサというあの言葉だけなんですね
変わるのは 銃は空と空と楽と不苦不楽
この苦・楽・不苦不楽の 3つの銃はサアミサかニラーミサかと
そうすると 6つになります
だから問題はサアミサってなんですか？ニラーミサってなんですかと
まあそれは説明してなくても構いません
なぜなら瞑想するとそれはまあ確認できないんだからね
で サアミサっていうのは
一応原因があって生まれてくる感覚なんですね
いわゆる対象があるんですね
で 目を開けて何か見る
ああ楽しいと なぜあの楽しみが生まれたんですか？目で何かを見ただからなんですね
だから今の自分の楽しみが
自分の目と見た対象に依存しているんですね
そうでなければ その楽しみは生まれないはずなんです
そこで耳に何か音が入ってくる
きれいな音楽だと気持ちいいと
それで楽の感覚が生まれるんですね
気持ちいいと なぜ気持ちいい感覚が生まれたかというと
耳があって そこに音というものが流れちゃったんだからなんです
だから自分の楽しみが
あのこの 2つの対象に依存しているんですよ
例えば ある時耳に入ってきた音楽を聞いた時の喜びを
その音楽なしに体験することできますか？じゃあ同じ楽しい気持ちをもう一回作ろうかなと
作れませんよ それだったらまた CDででも聴かなくちゃいけないし
あるいは自分で歌ってでも作らなくちゃならなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから そうやってこのものに依存して楽しみが生まれるんですね
まあわかりやすくて眼耳鼻舌身でしょうね
それに色色声香味触という
5つの対象があるんだからね
5つの対象とその受け取る五感がありますからね
そこから楽しみが生まれる
また苦しみが生まれる
また不幸 不楽が生まれる
ですから 人が自分が感じている楽苦
不苦不楽というものの半分というか
ほとんど眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報によって生まれているんですね
そういう全ての感覚がサーミサと言うんです
ディペンデントという
依存していると まあそういうことで
大体俗世間ではね まあそのサーミサという
まあ依存している まあ欲界と言ったってもいいですけどね
まあそういう苦と楽と不苦不楽しかないんですね
それでニラーミサって何でしょう
そちらの反対 何かに依存しないことで生まれる感覚
それを 3つに分けて苦と楽と不苦不楽に何かに依存しないと生まれる感覚
そこで耳にいろんな音が入ってきて
その時はいろんな楽も苦も不苦不楽も生まれてくる
そこで音が止まってもらう
止まったら生まれてくる感覚は何でしょうかと
音から離れる 離れた時もその感覚
何かの感覚はあるはずなんですね
それは苦か楽か不苦不楽かっていうのはもうわかりませんだけど
まあその感覚はニラーミサ感覚になっちゃうんですね
最初はわかりやすい 例えばすごい何か本を開けたところで
絵本を開けたところですっごいなんか見たことないすごい綺麗な絵があったりして
見たくなって あ これ綺麗やと
それ途端 誰かがその本を閉めて持っていったりすると
自分の対象が消えちゃったでしょ
見たい対象が見て楽しかったと
見せなかった瞬間で苦しく腹が立っちゃうでしょうね
そうすると なぜ今苦しい感覚があるかというと
この対象がなくなっちゃったんだからなんてね
ですね それも一時的にはもう睨み合いなんですけど
本当のにらみ合いっていうことじゃないんですけどね
そういう風にでも分析した方がいいんですね
音が入ると 綺麗な音だ
うるさい音だ 色々もう色々もう感覚が生まれてくる
音がなくなったらそこで生まれる感覚は睨み合いの感覚で
だから論理的に言えば
この食べて楽しがってる人には食べないようにしちゃうと
確実に苦しくなるでしょうと
音がうるさいと思ってる人にとっては
音が消えてあげて消してあげちゃったら
ああ 楽が生まれるだろうと
そういうふうには言えます
まあ それぐらいだとは言いますけど
一応わかりやすく わかりやすくやらなくてはならないんだからね
だから感覚観察する場合は
この両方観察しちゃうんですね
音が入ってうるさいって邪魔だと思ったら
これはまあうるさいんだから苦だと
その音が消えちゃって
もう音がないんだと 今の感覚は何ですか？と
だから前は三味線の苦
今は苦の代わりに楽が生まれたら
今は睨み合いの楽 あるいは風雨苦風楽で
まあただ落ち着いたと
じゃあ睨み合いの風雨苦風楽だと
と分けて見ればよろしいということで
この風雨苦風楽 まあ苦楽風雨苦風楽っていうのは
もうそれまたもういい加減なことで
このしっかりしたものではないんですね
音が入って楽が生まれたら
次に音が入ってまた楽が生まれるといえば数学的に正しいんだけどね
だから ある特色の音が入った
ある楽な楽しい感覚が生まれたと
だったら同じ特色の音が入ってると
また入るとまた同じの量の楽しみの感覚が生まれ出すなんですね
そうするとずっと繋げると楽しみが生まれるはずなんです
この感覚の世界ではそうじゃないんですね
ずいぶんいい加減で だから音が触れると楽しみが生まれたり
また音が触れると同じ質の音かもしれませんだけど
苦しみが生まれて また同じ質の音が入るというと
風雨苦風楽が生まれるかもしれませんしね
だから観察しないと人には知恵が生まれてこないんですね
で 観察していないんだから
音楽はいかに美しいかと
音楽を否定する人はみんな人格が悪いんだと思ってるでしょうね
逆なんです そんなに音楽を好ってるっていうことは
あまりにも頭が悪いっていうことなんですね
あのシェイクスピアのドラマでも
いつでもこのこの簡単な人の感情だから
もう音楽好きで もう文化的で
だから悪役を説明するときは必ず音楽を嫌うような言葉入れちゃうんですね
で 何でしたっけ？あのシャイロック？音楽は嫌い
窓を閉めなさい この連中の音楽が流れてくるんだからと娘に言うんですね
家の中までもううるさくてしょうがない
窓閉めろと そこでもうシャイロックは音楽は嫌い
なぜならば悪役だからね
そこでいい役をやってる人は
ものすごく遊んで 酒飲んで
音楽を奏でてという感じでやってるというの
それを同じ価値観で西洋映画に見ても
いつでも白人たちが 文化人たちが
音楽と酒と踊りと その世界で他の人々は汚くて
醜くて もうという風に
もうはっきりと差別感覚でもう映画作ったりする
で そういうからくりあることさえも知らない愚かどもが
ただバカを見ていて騙されるだけ
だから音楽だったらアメリカからでなければあかんとかね
で それでアフリカ音楽は音楽ではありません
そのアフリカの音楽をアメリカ人真似したら
アフリカ音楽ってすごいもんだとまたいい加減なこと言ったりして
だからもうどこまででもいい加減なんですね
何の論理もないんですね
だから外国人をバカにしようという番組あるでしょ
外国人テレビの番組呼んで色々喧嘩させるとかね
よく見てください アメリカ人が喋るものには
あの愚かどもたちがみんな賛成する
あのテレビから出てくる連中がね
まともなことを言うのはあのビートたけしだけ
彼が誰もバカにしようということではなくて
本当に立派な人なんです
彼が別に誰も貶そうと思うことではなくて
ちゃんとしたことを言うんですけど
また黒い眼鏡かけてる
大らかどもがいるんですね
気持ち悪い なんかお化けみたいな人が
名前わかりませんだけどね
必ずしももう馬鹿にする差別的な言葉ばっかりしか言わないんですね
日本でかなりインテリで認めている人でしょうと思いますけど
だからあれほど頭悪いと思いますけどね
で 彼もあのアメリカ人が言うと
うんうん まあまあその通りですよと
もしパキスタン人でバングラデシュなんか言ったら
お前ら何言ってるんですか？という感じで
もう私は誰の考え方も認めてないんだけど
みんなもういい加減なこと言ってますから
もうどうしたことはないんだけど
その中でもビートたけしはまああまりにも激しくなって言っちゃうと
何かすごいすっごいしっかりした言葉言って抑えるというのは
まあそれはさすがすごいなと思いますけどね
ですから もういい加減なんですよ
ただそちらからアメリカから流れると
それはいいもので アジアがない
それは悪いものでとかね
本気なんですよ 別にわざとではなくて
そう思っちゃうんですよ
だからそう言うんです
だから感覚っていうのはそんなに当てになるものなるものではないんですね
だから音楽にしたっても
この音楽は最高だと言っても
それはもう流れていって
じゃあ楽しい また流れちゃうと楽しいかというとそうではないかもしれませんし
だからすごい客観性持っちゃうと
綺麗にこの感覚っていうものは随分いい加減に流れていくものだなととわかるはずなんですね
それで価値消えちゃうんですね
例えばリンゴは美味しいんですよと
本当に客観性があって
食べてみて ある時は美味しくて
ある時は全然美味しくない
食べたくもないほどもう嫌っていうことになるはずなんですね
どんなものにもそういう風なあるんです
紅茶にしたっても コーヒーにしても
お茶にしたっても あ これすごく美味しいんですよと
いつでもそういうわけじゃないんです
だから依存すると これはすごい香りの良いお茶です
どこで買ったんですか？とか
それで調べて自分も買って飲もうとするんだけど
全く大はずれで それだったらそれはもうあの瞬間だけのいい加減な感覚なんですね
そういうふうにこの感覚の世界っていうのは
まあそうやってものすごいいい加減ということ
その時その時のことであって
それは観察しなくちゃいけないんですね
それはものから生まれる感覚
眼耳鼻舌身から生まれてくる感覚
苦楽 不苦不楽  A に対して B とか C に対して
そうやって決まりはありません
なのに人々は自分の楽の感覚をどうやって作ろうかなと外の世界で物を探していくでしょ
あれははずれです だからこの世の中では苦しみしかないんです
ある時はお金あってよかった時
じゃあお金もう 消そうとすると最高に楽しいと間違いんです
金が入るともう犯罪やらいろんな苦しみやらしなくちゃいけないはめになっちゃって
結局不幸で終わる可能性もありますね
だからこういう一つもそうやってこのしっかりしたことではないんです
だから ここでまた物に対する価値が消えるはずなんですね
ニラーミサっていうのは
そうやって厳密なニラーミサっていうのは
ものに依存しない時 音を聞いて聞いてる時の感覚と聞かない時の感覚
ものを見る時の感覚とものを見ない時の感覚ということなんですね
それも結局いい加減なんです
自分がそれは不苦不楽だと解釈しちゃったら
ほとんど不苦不楽で終わっちゃうんです
あ 楽しいと解釈しちゃったら
音が聞いてると やっぱりなんかすごく重みも感じて
重さ感じて苦しいんだと解釈したら
音がないとこはすごく楽しくて楽しいんだという風に解釈しちゃう
それでそれは続けちゃうんですね
残念ですけど なぜならば
あの依存しないんだから生まれることだから
ずっと生まれっぱなしで状態はできます
だから音が流してる時の感覚は一時的でしょう
音を消したと もう消したことだから
もう一時的という問題はないんですね
ずっとだから ですから
このニラーミサの感覚は一応観察すると
まあ長持ちしている感じはわかるんですね
ずっとではなくて まあ結構持つんですね
そこで 世の中でいろんな殺人をしながら生活することはすごく刺激的で楽しいと思う人にとっては
1時間  2時間でも世間から離れていることはすごい苦しくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この犯罪を起こしたり
いろんな大騒ぎのことをしてる人々はこのあのいろいろ実刑に
実刑というか 刑務所に入れたりするのは
もうその人にとってはすごく苦しみなんです
とにかく社会に出て たくさん金儲けて
いろんな人と喧嘩したりして
そういうことをやりたかったんだからね
それで犯罪を起こしちゃったんだから
刑務所だと そこで社会にももういろんなことをやりたくない
もう物事の関わりたくない人は
あなたは10年刑務所に入れますよって言ったら
全然もうああ良かったと
これ最高に楽しくなっちゃうんですね
ご飯作らなくてもいいし
で もうちゃんと時間に起こしてくれるし
時間のところ寝なさいと言うし
で 自分がちょっと怠けたいと思ったって
今運動の時間だとか言っちゃうし
だからやらなくちゃいけないし
で 今の仕事の時間だって言ったら
言ってたんでももう何のことなく仕事をしてもいい
そこで競争はないんだからね
ただ仕事をすればいいんだから
楽々に仕事できるし 普通の世界で仕事とは随分訳が違う
ものすごい楽しいんです
それでわからないことだったら教えてもらっちゃえばいいし
失敗したって あなた会社に損しましたとかね
そういうこともないし
だから だから世の中に関わりたい人にだけ刑務所は苦しい場所であって
関わりたくない人についてすれば
あれほどいいところはなくなっちゃうんですね
だから裁判でも入れてくれって言ったって入れてあげませんよ
普通の人をね  そのために罪を犯したって人を聞きました
入りたいために   その場合でもやっぱりまあまあそういうこともあるかもしれませんけどね
それとは別に社会と関わりたくないというわけじゃなくて
生活できないんだからなんですからね
そういうことで この関わりがあって生まれる次はアーミサで関わりがないことから生まれる次はニラーミサっていうことに分けてます
だから世の中から離れて静けさを楽しむ人にとっては
いくらでも楽しむことはできます
静けさを苦しみだと思う人にとっては
もうかわいそう  1時間
2時間でも静けさのところでいられなくなっちゃうんですね
で これはこのまあ 初期団体の感覚で
涅槃っていうのはこの住そのものの消えたことなんです
だからこちらでは涅槃と農家なんてないんですけどね
まあどちらも自然授記はそこまで持っていってないんだからね
基本的な瞑想の方だけだからね
まあそうやって感覚を分けてみると
それで感覚は生まれてくることを観察する
消えていくことを観察する
それで生まれて消えて生まれて消えてる流れを観察する
それで自分だけじゃなくて
まあそこら辺のこの世の中見ても同じことでね
人は音楽を聴いて楽しい感覚が生まれてるんだとかね
人二人が喧嘩していると
今音は流れてるんだけど
この人は嫌な感覚 この人の嫌な感覚作ってるんだと
明確に見えるでしょうに
この人今はこういう感覚を味わってる
この人 今苦しみの感覚を味わって
この人は今もう もうまあこういうまあ不苦不楽の感覚を味わっているとかね
自分のことを観察しておけば
もうものすごい簡単に見えます
それでただ感覚あるのみっていうことをわかってしまったところで
ただそれぐらいの感覚の世界だということで価値が消えてしまって楽になります
それは感覚の瞑想 それで残るのは心の瞑想
これは他の日にします
[終始背景音楽]